it's Michelle from Lab Muffin Beauty
science and I am a massive sunscreen
nerd since I talk about sunscreens all
the time
I've been asked by a lot of people to
review my favorite sunscreens so today
I'm going to be talking about my six
favorites from my sunscreen spreadsheet
which I've given a 5 plus rating in the
future I hope there'll be more sunscreens
joining this group if you like this sort
of video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to my channel and click the notification
bell so you don't miss any videos
everyone looks for different things in
the sunscreen my skin is not the same as
your skin so don't just go out and buy
these sunscreens and expect them to work
just as well for you as they did for me
if you want to work out what your skin
type and concerns are or if you want
more info on choosing and using a
sunscreen you can check out my book the
lab muffin guide to basic skincare so
here's what I look for in a sunscreen I
look for high UVA protection and that's
because I'm really really prone to
hyperpigmentation which is when you get
sunspots and when you get brown marks
after acne that don't fade for ages
and ages I have another video on this
topic so for high UVA protection I look
for a PA or PPD rating or I look for the
words broad spectrum from a place that
has stricter guidelines like Australia I
also look for the newer UVA filters all
of the sunscreens I'm talking about
today have these these are things like
Tinosorbs S and M, Uvinul A Plus and
Meroxyl SX and XL if you want to know more
about sunscreen ingredients there's a
free downloadable sample from the lab muffin
guide to basic skincare that goes
through some of the different UV filters
another really important factor for me
is lack of a white cast this is when you
apply your sunscreen and you see like a
sort of white film over your face I've
had this with every single inorganic or
mineral sunscreen I've tried so all of
the ones on this list are chemical or
organic my skin is actually still on the
pretty pale side it's NC 20 but I can
still notice this white cast when I
apply the full amount that I meant to I've
done a video in the past about the
differences between chemical and
physical sunscreens but for me
personally white cast has been the deal
breaker I have included one mineral
sunscreen in the honorable mentions at
the end of this
so if you prefer those sorts of
sunscreens stay tuned another really
important consideration for me is how
easy it is to apply the sunscreen I like
to be able to spread the sunscreen on
and not have to work it into my skin too
much and I really hate it when it pills
or balls up because I know that that's
protection that's just leaving my skin
whether or not a sunscreen pills or
balls up on you really depends on your
skin type so my skin is oily combination
and these ones have been fine for me I
like to apply my sunscreen really close
to my eyes because that's where all the
wrinkles are coming my eyes are pretty
resilient because I've been wearing
contact lenses for years but they do
still water with some sunscreens so this
is pretty important for me as well
obviously clogged pores are evil and my
skin really likes to clog up with
sunscreens I don't know why all of the
sunscreens I've been trying I've been
trying for at least two weeks and most
of them do clog my pores at some point
these six have not so onto the
sunscreens these six are my favorite so
far all of them are Asian or Australian
and I promise you that's not just
because they're like me and I love me I
haven't got any US sunscreens on there
because in the US the new UVA filters
haven't been approved yet so I don't
really like the chance of me getting a
high UVA protection factor sunscreen
there I also haven't got any European
sunscreens on the list and I think
that's because even though they do have
the newer UVA filters their sunscreens
tend to be a lot more heavy and I think
that's because they have a dry climate
and people tend to have dry skin I have
very oily skin and I live in Australia
so the texture just doesn't really work
for me so far the first sunscreen is
canmake's mermaid skin gel UV I've
decided to start with the Asian
sunscreens because they're a bit easier
for people to find and buy than
Australian sunscreens this is a really
really light textured sunscreen one of
the lightest sunscreens I've ever tried
and it's so light that sometimes I
wonder how sweat resistant it is it
sinks in really easily it works really
well under makeup and there's no alcohol
in it which is good if you're prone to
dehydrated skin it's unscented and
there's also no white cast which is
awesome I was actually surprised by the
fact that wasn't white cast because it
does contain some inorganic sunscreens
as well so this is a combo inorganic
and chemical sunscreen there are five
sunscreen actives in this they're
zinc oxide titanium dioxide uvinul a
plus tinosorb s and octinoxate I
don't really like titanium dioxide in
sunscreens because it tends to give you
white cast and it's also quite photo
reactive which means it makes other
things react in terms of skincare
ingredients in sunscreens I don't really
tend to care that much about them
because that's not what I'm using
sunscreen for they are a nice bonus but
I wouldn't go out of my way to choose
a sunscreen that has them the only
exception here is niacinamide which has
been found to boost the immune system so
it's good for preventing certain types
of skin cancer this does have plant
extracts which are antioxidant but the
main thing I like this sunscreen for is
it's incredibly light texture which is
really comfortable and a really nice
beginner sunscreen if you haven't been
wearing daily sunscreen before because
of the texture the next sunscreen is
Klairs Soft Airy UV Essence this is also
a really light water-based sunscreen
it's a little bit heavier than the
canmake one but it's still very very light
again it's alcohol free which is great
if your skin is dehydration prone it has
a really light scent as well there's two
sunscreen ingredients in this there's
uvinul a plus which protects against
UVA and octyl triazone which protects
against UVB there's been some
speculation that these two sunscreen
filters aren't enough to give you
protection against the full range of UV
wavelengths I think this comes from one
of two places firstly there's a lot of
incorrect info online about what
uvinul a plus does it does protect
against UVA1 and in fact BASF who
sell it sell it specifically as a UVA1
filter the other place where I think
this comes from is just people not quite
understanding how to read a UV
absorption graph the amount of UV
absorption depends on concentration as
well as the formula so the lines on the
graph will go up and down and if there's
an overlapping section you actually have
to take the two and add them together
to get an approximation of the
absorbance whenever you have theoretical
speculation versus actual empirical
evidence like an SPF test or a PA rating
then the actual test will always overrule
any theoretical speculation about what
the product can do as I said before you
can't predict how a recipe will taste if
you just look at the ingredients list
and I think this is what people are
doing in this case it's got SPF 50+
and PA++++ so it's maxed out
with both this has no white cast which
is not very surprising since it doesn't
have any inorganic filters it's got a
few skincare ingredients as well it's
got sea buckthorn oil which has
antioxidants it's also got allantoin and
beta glucan which are really good
moisturisers and niacinamide which is a
really good all-rounder ingredient I'm
reviewing both of these together because
they're incredibly similar sunscreens
these are the purito centella green
level safe sun & centella green level
unscented sun this is basically just the
unscented version of this one these two
have the same sunscreen ingredients as
the class and in terms of texture these
are the next step up after class they're
a little bit heavier but they're still
really really light and really
comfortable I'd say they're sort of like
a light lotion I do like the fact that
the texture is a little bit heavier
because it feels like it will last for a
little bit longer on your skin in hot
weather even though it hasn't been
properly tested with a water resistance
rating these glide on really smoothly
and it's really easy to apply a large
amount on your skin which is important
because if you don't apply enough you
won't get full protection I've also
found that sometimes lighter sunscreens
tend to feel like they're just gliding
around on your face and they're not
really sinking in and so you're just
moving it around and you can't add any
more but that's not the case with these
ones or the previous ones that I talked
about either they didn't sting my eyes
and they make a really good makeup base
in terms of extra skin care ingredients
they have obviously centella extract
which is the name of the line
there's also niacinamide as well as
hyaluronic acid and glycerin which are
really good humectant moisturisers the
difference between the two obviously
there's the scent which I've talked
about before the scent in this comes
from lavender oil as well as Roman
chamomile so if you're allergic to
either of those then you should go for
the unscented the other benefit of the
unscented version is that it's got extra
centilla extracts as well I've talked
about this sunscreen a lot before it is
the ultraceuticals daily moisturiser
SPF 30 this has been my favorite
sunscreen for a really long time and I
think a lot of it is just I'm really
nostalgic because this is the first
sunscreen that didn't give me clogged
pores after I used it for a long time
there are three versions of this
sunscreen there's the mattifying which
is this one there's a hydrating version
and there's an SPF 50 plus version as
well in terms of the texture the SPF 50
plus is a little
heavier and the hydrating is a bit stickier
so I tend to use all three because
the textures aren't that dissimilar but
I tend to use the hydrating and the SPF
50 plus more in winter I also really
like the convenient pump top which
apart from being convenient which is
great because I'm lazy it's also really
good for making sure that you're not
using less and less sunscreen over time
the downside is that it is quite pricey
and for ultraceuticals I don't mind
paying more as much because I know that
they invest a lot of money into research
and clinical trials and that makes me
feel better than if I'm buying a luxury
product from a brand that invests all of
its money back into marketing another
thing I really like about the ultraceuticals
sunscreen is that you can get a
full ingredients listing as well as the
active ingredients and their percentages
in Australia sunscreens are classified
as medications which means that they
don't need to show all the inactive
ingredients I really appreciate that
ultraceuticals have chosen to show
them anyway because I think it makes
it much easier if you are a somewhat
nerdy consumer in terms of actives it's
got octinoxate avobenzone ensulizole
and tinosorb s the next
sunscreen on my list is ultra violette
supreme screen and this is another brand
that's chosen to show the full
ingredients list it's also got a
convenient pump top and the packaging in
general is just really nice and fancy
ultra violette also make it really clear
how much sunscreen you should be
applying to your skin which I appreciate
because there's just not that much
consumer education about this from most
sunscreen brands ultra violette so far have
three sunscreens and the other two
didn't really work for my skin I do know
that lots of other people have found
that they work so I think it is more of
a skin type issue than a product issue
but this is the one for me this is a
lightweight sunscreen that feels like it
sinks in pretty quickly and it leaves a
silky primer finish which makes a really
good makeup base it doesn't pill up or
ball at all
it has a light scent the three sunscreen
ingredients in it are tinosorb s and M
as well as octinoxate I'm a bit
cautious about tinosorb M because it's
an organic sunscreen but it does tend to
give a bit of white cast because it has
a physical action like it reflects and
scatters some light for this sunscreen I
didn't have any issues with white cast
supreme screen is designed to be
really hydrating so it's got lots of
humectants it's got glycerin butylene
glycol and saccharide
isomerate there is alcohol near the top
of the ingredients list but it's still
really hydrating and I think it's
because the humectants and the sunscreen
overpower the alcohol's dehydrating
effect overall my skin just felt really
hydrated when using it it also has some
antioxidants it's got kakadu plum
extract and it's got l-carnosine as
well the downside to the sunscreen is
the price per mL it's actually more
expensive than the ultraceuticals but
it does come in a smaller pack which
means that upfront the cost is a bit
lower
the final sunscreen on my list is
azclear's day moisturizer SPF 30 this is
made by ego pharmaceuticals who also
make sunsense and QV and it's part of
their azclear range which is a range of
products designed to work with an
azelaic acid treatment the reason I'm so
excited about the sunscreen is that it's
really really light and it's also really
really budget-friendly it is light but
it is really humectant heavy so it's
really hydrating and it does tend to dry
down a little bit on the sticky and dewy
side I've only tried it in winter so far
so it's been fine but I do wonder how it
will hold up on my skin in summer cos
I'm quite oily I think if your skin is
drier then it will be much better for
you it does only have SPF 30 but it's
easy to apply a lot and if you can apply
a lot of an SPF 30 it still ends up
probably being better than applying a
tiny bit of an SPF 50 plus the active
ingredients in this octinoxate tinosorb
s and uvinul a plus this does work
well under makeup even though it doesn't
really have that primer finish it's more
of like a moisturiser finish and one of
the problems I've had with ego
sunscreens in the past is that some of
them tend to ball up when you're
applying makeup it hasn't been a
problem at all with this I have some
honorable mentions which have missed out
on being one of my Holy Grail sunscreens
because of one small issue firstly
there's the purito comfy water sunblock
which is purito's inorganic sunscreen
the reason this didn't make it into my
top is because it does give a tiny white
cast it has the least white cast of any
inorganic sunscreen I've ever tried it
feels really light but it has enough
white cast that when I put on my foundation
it looks like it's not quite the right
colour so that is still a deal-breaker
for me but if you're lighter if it's not
such a big deal for you then this is a
really low white cast inorganic
sunscreen there's also the natio
daily defense moisturizer this is the
one that I tend to recommend to friends
and co-workers in Australia because it's
really easy to find in stores it's
really light and it feels like a nice
moisturiser and it's frequently on sale
the mecca to save face
super screen SPF 50 plus is quite
similar in texture but it does tend to
be a little bit pricier my backup
recommendation is the Coles facial
sunscreen this is a little bit heavier
but it is really really cheap my final
mention is the Bioderma photoderm
sunscreens these have the highest PPD
levels I've seen on the market so
they're great for UVA protection my only
issue is that they're a little bit heavy
for me and they tend to clog my pores so
those are my favorite sunscreens so far
leave me a comment if you have a
sunscreen that you think I would really
enjoy that might make my cut for my next
favorite sunscreens video give it a
thumbs up if you liked this video you
can also subscribe to my channel and
click the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos you can also check me
out on instagram at lab muffin beauty
science you can look at my blog
labmuffin.com and I will see you next time